Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Oh my God, I sound... I'm like, every day is an improvement for my voice.
Every day I'm like, oh my God, I sound so much... Yes, yes, I have eye bags right now, because this is how I feel every day.
This is how I feel every day last half year.
I felt like, you know, gotta be true to myself, guys.
Like, I gotta be true to myself.
But yeah, sorry, I'm a little late, because I thought I had everything tested out.
I thought everything was good.
And then, like, I was like, wait, why can't I stream it?
Like, why wouldn't it show up on my OBS?
But I forgot, because it's an old game.
This is a modded game.
By the way, they modded this so that you could play it now on Windows 11.
But yeah, the perks of being an indie.
Like, oh, did you ask perms for this?
What perms?
This is abandonware.
Like, the game is practically abandonware right now.
Next scene, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, this is my default now.
This is actually how I feel inside and outside.
But yes, like, just like, I don't know if you guys remember, but like a lot of older games, you need to run it through admin only...
to be able to stream such games.
But this one, there's a lot.
I was like, this one, the thing is, it has its own special launcher to be able to play this game.
Because it is like, like the community modded this game to be able to play now.
Because apparently, apparently, because this game was made by EA, but EA was never going to pay.
I don't know, not, maybe not never, but like at its current time, they weren't going to pay for the rights to re-release this game, like remaster it or whatever.
So, to be able to play the Battle of Middle-Earth, you have to be, the community modded the game to be able to play online.
And so, that's how I've been able to play.
Because I tweeted, I mean like, I miss Battle of Middle-Earth.
And then people like linked me to a bunch of posts on how you could play it now.
So yeah, thank you to all the Dragoons that linked it to me.
I would have known that you could actually play this game now.
But yeah, I'm really excited.
Apparently online works as well, but I'm going to be playing the campaign mode.
And we're going to do the evil campaign, because I honestly enjoyed, I don't know, every time I play, like for some reason, I really enjoy the evil characters when I play RTS games.
Because I feel like the character designs and like the troops and everything is just so much better.
It just looks nicer.
And it's much more, the story, I like the story a lot more.
I like the story a lot more.
I like the troop designs a lot more.
I just love controlling the evil, like bad guys more than the good guys.
Because like the good guys, you get elves, you get elves, dwarves, humans.
But they're just all different flavors of like human.
So if you think about it, elves, dwarves, humans, it's like small human, small human, human with pointy ears, and then human.
But so it's like, it's so boring.
I just, and then, but then, you know, I guess you also have the trees too.
But like, you know, I fucking hate the trees because of Groot.
Don't compare dwarves with knife ears.
How dare you?
It's just, it's just different flavors of human features.
So like, or the hob, you know, or small, or even smaller human.
So it's like hobbits, the smallest human.
Then dwarves, the like medium-sized human.
Human, human size.
Then elves, taller, tall humans with knife ears.
So it's like, and then tree guy.
And then tree men.
So like, I always find the troops like incredibly boring to play as.
So that's why I always play the, like my go-to has always been like the evil campaign.
And like, and like just playing the evil characters.
Cause it's like, I feel like the designs are a lot cooler.
Like we get like, like goblins on dogs.
Like they ride on dogs and stuff like that.
And then we get dragons and everything.
So, yeah, exactly.
Lord Kuro says, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagine getting to choose what you are in a fantasy setting and you choose to be a human.
Holy fuck.
Okay, I didn't mean like that, but okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yabby, thank you for the super chat.
Toki, I've called Marvel rivalitis.
Please see a doctor.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Imagination, thank you for the super chat.
A sequel is even better.
Yeah, I was debating if I want to play Battle Metal 2 or the first one.
But I figured since like, you know, I figured I'd try to go with the first one.
Since it's like the first one in the installment.
And it's the one that got me really into the game at first.
By the way, so I'll tell you about my history of Lord Rings.
Lord Rings looks like racism.
Guys, L's aren't real.
And so are dwarves.
Dwarves aren't real at all.
They're not real.
Anyway, they aren't real to me.
How can you be racist to a thing that doesn't exist?
I wasn't even the one that blinded Knife Ears.
I was just reading off of chat.
I wasn't even the one that suggested Knife Ears.
I was just saying the good side is just boring to play as.
Not so deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
L's and dwarves are just fantasy meters and we don't know how you feel about those people.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Okay, don't keep saying slurs on stream now.
Anyway, anyway.
Okay, so a lot of people know.
Some of you guys might know about my history with Lord of the Rings.
So, I actually didn't really grow up with Lord of the Rings.
I'm not a Lord of the Rings fan, but I loved Battle of Middle-Earth.
And I loved the RTS, Battle of Middle-Earth 1 and 2.
And I never actually played the Wraith game.
I never played that one because by the time that game came out, it was too late for me.
I think by the time that game came out, for some reason, I didn't play it.
My dad never bought it, so I never was able to...
Rise of the Witch King, yeah, Rise of the Witch King.
I never got a chance to play it because my dad never bought it.
So, the only reason why I was able to play those games was they were hand-me-downs from my dad.
So, my dad loves Lord of the Rings.
Like, he was obsessed with the entire franchise of Lord of the Rings.
So, he watched all the movies, he played all the games.
He dragged me to watch the second Hobbit movie.
I didn't watch the first one because I was just like...
I wasn't really that interested.
The one with Smaug or whatever his name...
Is it Smaug?
Is he in the first or second...
No, he was in the second one.
He dragged me to watch the Smaug one, but I never watched the first one.
But he dragged me to watch that one.
And then the third one, he asked me if I wanted to watch it.
I was like, no, it's alright.
But basically, my dad was obsessed with the entire franchise.
He owns all the behind-the-scenes DVDs of the Lord of the Rings and everything.
And then he tried to drag...
And he went to theaters to watch the Lord of the Rings movies and everything.
And he loved the franchise.
And because he loved the franchise, he also loved the games too.
So he gave me the hand-me-downs of the RTS Lord of the Rings games to play when I was little.
But I only was able to play one and two.
And that's why I think that those...
I think my favorite RTS games of all time has to be Battle on Middle-Earth and StarCraft.
Like StarCraft, my favorite race to use has to be the Zerg.
Because I'm always interested in...
I've always thought the Zerg designs were much more interesting.
And the Zerg troops were much more interesting than the Protoss and the fucking humans.
And I think their lore and story is so much more interesting too.
Protoss was just way too...
The Protoss lore and story was just too...
How do I say it?
What's the proper word for it?
It's just too snobby for me.
I don't know.
I feel like the Protoss story was way too...
I'm trying to think of a word for it.
A good...
Pretentious.
Yeah, that's a good word.
I just thought Protoss was really pretentious.
And then humans were just humans.
Yeah, they're literally just space elves.
If you think about it.
They're like space elves.
And I always thought the Zerglings...
The Zerg story was just much more interesting.
And the same with Battle of Middle-Earth.
I just thought the evil campaign was just more interesting than the good campaign.
Because it's like the other side of Lord of the Rings.
You're always following the good guys.
So this time you get to follow the bad guys.
And it's like a what-if situation.
Oh, what if the bad guys just win it all?
What if Soran just won?
I was like, that's a cool idea.
That's pretty neat.
I was like, yeah.
What if Soran just win it all?
The bad guys deserve to win sometime.
So I always thought like...
I thought it was interesting.
I just thought the story was just much more interesting.
Anyway, I don't remember much about the campaign.
Because it's been like...
Yeah, what if he was just misunderstood?
You guys don't know.
He might have been just a misunderstood guy.
You guys don't know that.
We're gonna play his story.
Simpleminded, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Man, the new Doki situation is crazy.
You think you have learned from last time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Ryan, I have a protest against this racist streamer.
Report it.
Spoken like a true space elf.
Thank you for the super chat, Ryan.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, how could you?
Terrans aren't just humans.
They're a space trucker.
Oh, yeah, brother.
Hit that dead rock, Terran1.
Thank you for the super chat, Anton.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
Alright, the dwarves were right.
Darkblade.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Miss Doki Bird, I need to know.
Did you see the trailer leak of the cancelled CW Powerpuff Girls show?
I remember you talked about the script leak.
Yes, I have!
For those who didn't know, I remember I always said, I wish they would just leak the cancelled Powerpuff Girls show.
And someone finally leaked it.
I was like, oh, man.
I wish one day...
I can't believe we live at a time where someone actually leaked the Powerpuff Girls live-action CW show.
I wish this show actually came out.
I would have hate-watched the shit out of it.
It's so bad, but so fun.
It's like funny bad, though.
Like, I know all you guys are like, this is fucking terrible.
But it is funny bad.
It looks like a fucking train wreck that I would absolutely watch and consume.
Because I watched Supernatural when it got bad bad.
I fucking ate that shit.
Supernatural at one point was good.
But then it got bad bad.
And I still... I did stop at one point because it went...
And I watched Riverdale too.
The thing is, I watch trashy shows.
And it looked like another...
Like, it looked like Riverdale as well.
And I was like, oh my god.
This could have been my next Riverdale.
This legit...
It looked so good.
It could have...
It would have been my pre-Riverdale if I was able to...
Oh, no.
They copyright striked it.
No way.
Oh my god.
Somebody...
Oh, I was gonna show you guys a link.
They actually...
Someone must have it.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna see if I can find it.
I'm gonna try to see if I can find it.
But they actually...
They copyright striked it.
I can't believe it.
It's actually gone.
Wait.
Let's see if there's the...
I'm gonna see.
There was a long trailer too.
It was like fucking a long ass trailer.
I was surprised with how long that trailer was when I was watching.
I was like, it's still going?
Oh my god.
Jokey, you definitely should have played Warhammer 40,000, your favorite video game of that franchise.
Just listening to you.
Joel, thank you for the Akka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, there was...
Imagina, thank you for the Magenta Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Starcraft Brood War.
Starcraft 2 this year then?
I mean, it was a charity goal.
So, definitely for sure this year.
Best, thank you for the Magenta Super.
Thank you, thank you.
It's still on Reddit?
Okay.
Alright guys.
I'll see if I can find it.
I'll link you guys this before we play the game.
But I was just like, I can't believe we live...
It's 2025 and someone actually leaked it.
I can't...
It was real.
I thought we would never see it.
I never thought we live in a time where the show actually got...
It's so fucking...
Oh my god.
I...
It's actually funny.
I got it.
Alright.
For those who want to watch it.
Oh my...
Like...
Oh my god.
Okay.
My favorite part...
Okay, so like...
Spoilers.
So like, the thing is...
Mojo Jojo isn't a monkey anymore.
It's like a son and a father.
So like, the dad's name is Mojo.
And the son's name is Jojo.
And then...
And then they're trying to say that Jojo and Blossom were gonna fall in love or some shit.
I was just like, why?
Why is it Mojo and Jojo?
And then also...
Also, so like, they all like split up.
And then Buttercup became a firefighter.
And she's like, I'm a real hero now.
I was like...
You were an actual superhero that saved the world.
What the fuck do you mean?
You could have done that as a superhero.
You don't need to be a firefighter to be a hero.
You could have been a superhero that stopped fires.
Like, you don't have to be a firefighter.
You have superpowers.
So, yeah.
And then like...
And then Bubbles became like...
Like, tried to go to Hollywood.
But like, she couldn't make it.
And then it implied that she's like...
Like, I don't know.
A hooker?
I don't fucking know.
It implied that she's like doing something in Hollywood.
I have no idea.
And then, I don't remember what Blossom was doing.
Yeah, I know.
And then like...
Yeah, so like...
Yeah, so...
And I don't know what the fuck Blossom is doing.
Like, I don't know.
She's just there.
What am I yapping about?
The cancelled CW Powerpuff Girls show.
I wish...
I wish they could release the entire...
And then they're implying that the Powerpuff Girls show cartoon is based off of them.
Because like, they were superheroes that like...
That has like an entire like franchise built off of them.
So, and then like...
Okay.
This line like fucking cracked me up.
Because I was like...
Because they were...
Okay, it's so fucked up.
They were implying that the live action show...
Like, in the script...
The script, Buttercup was like...
Yeah, the Powerpuff Girls cartoon show whitewashed us.
And I was like...
Why would you write that bitch cartoon show?
Oh my god.
I was like...
That is insane.
That is actually insane.
That you would write that line for a beloved cartoon show.
That like started everything.
Oh my god.
I was like...
Holy fuck.
Why are you trash talking the original cartoon?
That's absolutely crazy.
I wish this show didn't get cancelled.
I would have watched this.
I would have made you guys watch this.
It is so bad funny.
Like, from the trailer alone...
By the way...
The show...
The time of the show when this was written...
Was when Tumblr was still a thing.
Because I remember when I was on Tumblr...
That people were talking about the live action Powerpuff Girls show.
And I could tell that this was very geared towards Tumblr women.
Just from this...
It was like when Tumblr was still around...
This show was being filmed and written.
Because I was there on Tumblr when they were talking about this.
I fucking...
Oh man.
This would have been my pre-Riverdale, guys.
This actually would have been my pre...
I wish they brought it back.
I wish somebody would just leak the entire fucking...
Like, all the episodes right there.
It was made for me.
This show was made for me to watch.
To watch and like...
To hate watch.
I linked the trailer for anyone that wanted to watch it.
Anyway...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rings of Power.
Basically gave Middle Earth the CW treatment.
But you have to know the books to truly appreciate how awful it is.
Sorry, I'm a Tolkien fan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton.
Petitioned to add bad CW shows to members' watch logs.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
OmniStar.
Thank you for your very first super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Balfour Miller came out in 2004.
I was 11.
Man, I feel old.
I grew up on the game and the 3rd Age Total War mod for Medieval 2 Total War.
Great memories and led me to play Dungeons & Dragons.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god.
But yeah, thank you for your very first super chat.
Anyway, enough about the Powerpuff Girls.
Let's actually play the game.
So apparently, this is like...
The HD mod.
Oh, wait.
Why is it not...
Wait, why is it not showing anymore?
Wait, it worked before.
Excuse me?
Oh no.
Wait a minute.
It was working.
It showed up on my OBS.
Oh no, I talked too long.
I talked too long.
Okay, let me...
Let me reload.
Let me reboot this.
Maybe if I reboot it, it'll work.
At least because I tabbed out.
Maybe that's why.
Okay, don't worry guys.
I figured it out.
Guys, don't worry.
I know how to do this.
I figured it out.
Run as admin.
There we go.
This was...
Yeah, my...
Too much Powerpuff Girls.
The game was like, stop.
Yeah, I guess we can't tab out, guys.
We can't tab out.
Alright, here we go.
Options.
Let me know...
Sound guy, if you're alive.
Let me know if everything's okay.
Let's do...
Yeah, let's do ultra.
I don't know.
Let's do with the movie up.
I feel like movie and voice is...
Alright, let's put these up.
I feel like these are always have to go.
Woah!
I legitimately don't remember this game much.
I just remember controlling the units.
Alright.
Campaign.
Evil.
Let's do medium.
We're not pussies.
But like, we are a little bit...
But we're not like, good enough for hard yet.
I don't remember this game as much.
Alright.
Where are we?
Guys, I need you guys to know that like...
I am not very well versed in the Lord of the Rings lore.
A lot of things I know was reading the Lord of the Rings Wikipedia.
And also Battle of Middle-Earth.
That's...
Woah.
Let's get that one ring back.
And they're taking the hobbits to Isengard.
Isengard.
They're taking the hobbits to Isengard.
Taking what?
Isengard.
No subs.
Ooh, Christopher Lee.
Alright.
Okay, so...
Let us...
Fix the audio real quick.
What was it?
So, let's get the voices...
Alright, so apparently...
There's no subtitles.
Back then...
Games usually did not have subtitles.
Because games back then...
They were like, fuck you guys.
Why do you need to read?
Like...
They prefer not giving us subtitles back then.
Because they think we don't need to read.
We just need to listen.
Back then.
Okay, we're turning the music down.
And the sound effects down.
And that should be good.
Alright, sound guy.
Is everything good?
Gamers don't need to read.
That's how they thought back then.
Alright.
Let's go.
You don't need to understand Lord of the Rings lore to roll Middle-Earth Queen.
Tokid Save.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Me!
I'm the new master.
That's me!
Oh, I forgot to accept changes.
Oops.
Oh my god.
You can tell how old this game is.
The cinematics.
Rosie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I owned this and haven't touched it.
I'm so happy to watch you play.
Oh my god.
This...
Woah.
Okay, there's grandma.
There's sorrow man.
Okay, I need to remember how to play this.
Left-click or right-click to move them.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
I remember this.
Okay.
Spinal damage through a large.
50% damage.
Okay.
I think I used it.
I got this first.
I remember.
Left-click then right-click to move.
Oh my god.
This is like actual...
Jesus Christ.
Why is Gandalf so fucking loud?
Oh my god.
They're fighting.
Look at him go.
Wait.
Why is my sorrow man so fucking weak?
No.
Sorrow man.
What?
What happened?
Bro.
I thought this was a 1v1.
Guys, I don't remember the campaign.
I told you guys.
I just remember controlling units.
It's been like...
It's been like a long time since I've played.
I...
How did...
I thought this was a 1v1.
Sorrow man.
How the fuck was I supposed to know you wanted help?
Oh my god.
I thought this was an honorable fight.
I legitimately thought we were 1v1ing.
There is no 1v1 here.
I don't...
The sun was in...
I had to change my...
I had to change my fucking...
Okay.
Sound guy.
What do I have to fix for sound?
But you're the evil...
I might be evil, but I still have honor.
Like...
I got filtered by Gandalf the Great.
Evil...
I thought we were having an honor system with 1v1s.
I was...
Nah, joking.
You guys.
He literally rode up and beat...
Like, I thought this was like an old man fighting.
I was like, oh shit.
Cool.
A 1v1 with old men.
Like...
Okay, movie down.
Alright.
I don't know.
I don't know if it was like...
Evil never prospered.
Okay.
We'll just do this for now.
I was not expecting that.
He just rode up and fucking killed me.
He...
He literally...
Gandalf just rode up and fucking beat up my other...
My old man.
Holy fuck.
I was not expecting that.
I legitimately...
Like...
I don't know.
Well, now that I know he's gonna fucking show up.
I'm fucking sending people here.
There we go.
Can't be that bad now, right?
Like...
Sorry, man.
Okay.
What is my...
Chop down the trees...
In Eisendrath to uncover...
Found...
Recruit 50...
Build...
Okay.
That I can do.
I'm literally going in like right up, right away.
Like, they're chopping right now.
Like, what the fuck am I...
Okay, there he goes.
There he comes back.
He's back.
He's back, guys.
The old man is back.
Don't worry!
Round two.
Get over here!
Help him!
Saruman!
I...
What?!
Kill him!
There's no way!
How the fuck...
I don't understand!
I don't unders...
What if he just fucking kills me?
Okay.
I can't control Saruman.
He won't let me control him.
I don't...
No!
You don't understand!
I clicked Saruman...
And he's like...
He won't let me control him.
I don't...
I clicked on him.
I don't know why he refused to let me control him.
Like, it's actually crazy.
He won't let...
I didn't...
I don't remember this.
Okay.
I can't move past here!
That is so fucked!
I actually can't...
Oh my god!
I actually can't move this specific area.
Wait!
There's no way!
I have to listen to this again!
I don't understand!
How is he...
Saruman, don't!
Don't!
Saruman!
Saruman, get out!
Oh my god, I can!
I can move him now!
Get out!
Go Saruman!
This isn't a 1v1 anymore!
Run!
I can move him!
Kill him!
I can't kill him!
He won't let me kill...
Oh my god, you fucker!
Oh my god, he just runs away like a bitch!
Oh my god!
Okay, Saruman is okay now.
Guys, everything is okay.
I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out.
Oh my god.
Alright, he can run now.
Guys, he can run.
I don't have abilities open yet, guys.
Oh my god.
Thank fucking god.
Everything is okay, guys.
Okay.
Everything is okay.
Alright, what were my objectives now?
What were...
What were my...
What were my objectives?
Holy fuck.
That was scary.
That was actually scary, guys.
Oh my god, good job, Saruman.
You just stay here.
Like, it's fine.
You just...
I don't trust you.
Okay, let's just walker it.
Wait, what?
What's over here?
Oh, I can build more trees, though.
Nice.
Alright.
What were my objectives?
We need 50.
I can make 50.
That's fine.
And then I'll make another boat.
And then we'll have more wood.
Let's go!
Fuck the environment.
Oh, yes!
We get to kill trees!
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck.
Okay, um...
Don't worry.
I'm heading over.
Oh, shit.
Maybe I should be over here.
Alright, don't worry, buddy!
Don't worry!
Alright.
Go!
Get over there!
Burn the trees!
This is it!
This is what you were bent to do!
There we go!
Go!
Kill the trees!
Burn the trees!
Burn all the trees!
Oh my god, Saruman!
Saruman, you gotta... Oh my god, beam him!
Saruman, please!
Beam him!
That's right!
What the fuck are you doing?
Okay, there we go.
See, look at that.
Fuck the trees.
Guys, see?
I can learn.
See, guys?
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Okay, get that.
Just keep cutting down the trees and everything will be fine.
Uh...
Everything will be fine, guys.
We don't need to spy on anybody.
Oh, fuck!
Okay!
Um...
Uh...
Get over here!
Alright, there we go.
Don't worry.
Inspire.
Inspire them.
Whoa, so inspiring!
Alright, there you go.
See, look at that.
Ever since...
Ever since I figured it out, guys.
I figured it out, everyone.
I...
I just had to get through the first hurdle.
Which was Saruman.
I...
I just...
I just had to get through the first hurdle.
Which was Gandalf.
Gandalf was like...
Was the hardest part about this entire game.
For some reason.
That's all.
I don't know why.
Gandalf was so fucking hard.
Okay, nice.
Everything should be fine.
Get those L's out of here.
I mean, he is Gandalf.
We figured it out, everyone.
We figured it out.
Everyone is...
We're all okay now, guys.
We're all okay.
This Pokemon fight is nuts.
Oh my god.
That shit went fucking hard.
Wait, I cut up all the trees.
I'm running out of trees to cut, guys.
This is not good.
I'm actually...
Oh shit, not...
Okay.
Guard here.
Alright, that's good.
I am running...
I am running out of trees.
I am running out of trees to cut.
I wish I could farm these trees.
Don't worry, Saruman.
Let's just do that.
And then...
Inspire.
I can't inspire people yet.
There we go.
It's fine.
We have more people coming in.
More people are coming in.
Where are my other archers?
Wait, are they all dead?
How are they all dead already?
Okay, we'll keep farming.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can...
We're okay.
This is like...
We're not very healthy right now, but it's okay.
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, I lost some bread!
Bread man!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can rebuild.
We can always rebuild, everyone.
We can always rebuild.
It's fine.
We're rebuilding.
And then we'll get fire.
It's okay.
You know what?
Just inspire this particular...
Oh my god, they're trying to kill my little men.
Okay.
Get the fire arrows in.
We can always rebuild, guys.
Okay, yeah.
We're definitely running out of...
We're running out of stuff right now.
It's okay.
The tree is just going on a little stroll.
Okay, nice.
Everything is fine.
We just simply rebuild ourselves.
And then just...
Keep getting wood, I guess.
Yay!
Oh wait, not yay!
Wait, not yay!
No, wait!
Wait!
Oh shit!
Oh shit, get over here!
Get over here!
Oh shit!
Wait, I wasn't ready!
Wait!
Oh, fuck!
Where are they coming from?
Okay.
Oh, that's a lot.
Um, that's fine.
We'll guard here.
That's fine.
We can...
We'll be okay, guys.
We'll...
We'll be...
Oh, wait, can I close the gate?
No, they won't let me!
They won't let me close the gate!
They're like, I can take them.
My people are like, I can take them.
But what if I can't?
What if...
What if I can't take them?
Okay, wait.
Am I running out... Do I not have trees anymore?
I don't have trees anymore.
Bro, they're not even fucking farming trees anymore!
Because I don't have trees!
Cut these trees.
Get out.
Get outside and cut these trees.
Um...
Oh, they do?
Get up top.
It's sad.
I have three of them.
Oh, this is bad.
This is...
Okay.
I might have too many crossbows.
I think I realized...
I might have...
I might have recruited too many crossbows.
Just...
Oh, um...
Um...
This is a little... It's okay, I have him.
He'll be here.
He'll be here to be part of this.
He's here too.
Um, I think it's okay.
I think we're fine.
We'll be fine.
We're so fine.
Everything...
Alright, I can take them.
I can take them.
Don't worry.
I might have accidentally...
Made all crossbows.
But I can take them.
There you go.
It'll be fine.
It'll be so fine.
These guys...
You just stay there.
You'll stay there.
It's okay.
Build 16.
What am I gonna do with 16?
Finish the level.
Oh my god.
What can I build?
I don't even have trees anymore to build this.
They're cutting trees outside my building.
Alright.
Oh my god.
You know what?
Let's just...
Let's just casually build more of these just in case, you know.
Let's just... We have the money.
We might as well, you know.
Just one, two...
Oh gosh.
Okay.
They'll come over.
Get the pikemen.
Do I have pikemen?
Guys, I don't think I have any.
I only have these guys.
These are my only pikemen.
All the others died.
Did you know Christopher Lee actually won an Oscar for his performance in a scene where Saruman runs in circles away from Gandalf?
Thank you for the superchat, BladeWing.
Thank you.
Come on!
Fight me!
I ain't scared.
I'm a little scared.
Fight me!
Ride in!
Do it!
Don't be a pussy!
Oh wait, I have an extra bow arrow guy.
Ride in!
Goodbye!
I have to bait them in?
Okay.
I can always recruit this guy.
It's fine.
Alright.
That's fine.
I can use him.
You can die.
It's fine.
That's right!
Oh!
Oh, he didn't see me.
He didn't see me.
Okay.
Your mom's a whore!
That's right!
Oh my god!
Please shoot them!
Please!
Shoot them!
Oh my god!
Keep shooting!
Oh!
All mistakes are definitely made.
Oh my god!
Guys, I'm a little...
Guys, I...
This is not looking so good right now.
Oh my god!
They're coming over!
Where are you?
Get out of here!
Get out!
Holy shit!
Just let them die!
Just let them...
Don't be a hero!
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
See?
We're all okay.
Look at that!
Everything is fine.
I told you.
We lost him.
We lost him again, but we'll bring him back.
You...
No, Saruman needs to relax after what we did.
Look, see?
Nothing to be worried about.
We did it!
Masterfully played.
Yay!
We did it!
Look, guys.
Saruman has been through a lot.
He's like...
He got fucked up by Gandalf like three times, guys.
He needed to rest.
He needed to rest, guys.
Oh my god, we did it!
Alright, nice.
That was easy.
See, guys?
Look at that.
That was so easy, guys.
Oh, okay.
Wait, can I spend it now?
I wonder if I have to save...
Okay, new save files.
That's my save file.
Yay!
Okay, let me see the sound guy.
Overall, I'm bringing down the mood.
Movie slider?
Okay.
Don't worry, I got you.
Okay, options.
Overall.
And then bring down the movie.
Okay, I'll put this.
This.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
Alright.
Now that the hard part is over.
This should be smooth sailing now, right?
Oh my god, we get to burn more trees?
It's Christmas!
It's my birthday!
Every villain is lemons.
Oh my god, finally!
What I actually wanted to do this entire time.
Okay.
Yeah,
fuck the trees!
Finally!
We're playing my video game!
We're playing my video game now!
Oh shit!
Oh fuck, okay.
That's not cool.
Oh shit, okay.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's okay.
It's okay, we don't need him.
We never needed him.
Okay, three...
I want to get the...
Okay, I want the tree one.
I want this one.
Alright, nice.
Okay, so we gotta get there.
Alright, Saruman!
I believe in you!
I believe in you, old man!
Oh shit!
You know what?
It's just one guy.
That's fucking right.
You know what?
Fuck you.
That's right, stupid elves.
That's right, you think I won't?
Boom!
There you go.
You're 1v1 me?
Oh my god, you're still alive?
Get out of here!
Boom!
Alright.
You think I won't?
You're just... you're nothing!
Okay, there's a lot.
Nevermind, let me...
Okay, give me a sec.
Let me bring the entire army now.
Let me...
Okay, that was a mistake.
There was more than two guys.
What the fuck?
Get over here.
Alright, get over here.
Saruman is just bait.
There we go.
Guys, literally, what the fuck?
Why does it take you 20 years to kill them?
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Now we go!
It's okay, everything is fine now.
Look at that, we got our cap.
Nice.
Alright, we're fine now, guys.
Guys, it's okay.
Okay, I can reveal the location.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's a lot.
Wait, they're just all one people.
It's just all one guy.
I'm not gonna get one guy.
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Let's go, Saruman!
Let's go!
Beat this guy up!
Fuck him!
Use the devastation power to clear trees?
No, fuck it.
I still have time for this.
Wait, did I not...
Oh shit, did I not claim this?
Sorry, I...
Did you lose all your marble keys?
This is a forced stream.
No, I actually...
I actually won my games.
I just feel...
You know, you don't get a lot...
Oh, slaughterhouse, wait.
Alright, let's get slaughterhouse.
You know, you don't get a lot of time to, like, you know, be evil for once, you know?
For once in your lives.
Don't you get tired of being good?
Don't you wanna go ape-batshit crazy sometimes?
Sometimes...
Sometimes I'm tired of being good.
Sometimes I just wanna fucking kill people.
Like, but like, you know, like...
Not like that, but...
In-game.
In-game, guys.
Don't you sometimes just wanna, you know...
Kill...
Kill elves?
Is that too much to ask for?
Don't you just, you know...
Don't you guys ever thought about killing some elves?
If they were real?
Cause they're not real, guys.
Just remember, they're not real.
Okay.
What's over here?
Oh, fuck that one guy in particular, though.
Like, what is he gonna do?
What's over here?
Is there anything in here?
Oh, shit.
Friends?
Oh my god, friends!
Let's go!
Nice.
We have friends now.
Okay.
Yeah, fuck this one guy, too, in particular.
That's fucking right.
Wait, where's my other big boys?
Alright, let's see.
Block formation.
Alright, that's fine.
You know what?
Let's grab food.
Reduce costs of wargriders.
Upgrades.
Reduce...
Let's just get this.
And then...
That's fine.
Alright, let's go!
Fuck yeah!
Let's go, Isengard!
I gotta like...
Alright, let's just get these guys.
Over here.
And then these guys.
You know what?
Just go fucking...
Let's just...
Alright, use that fireball!
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's just kill anything you wanna kill.
That's right.
Just go crazy.
Do whatever the fuck you want.
Saruman can take these guys.
Oh, shit, let's go!
Go, Saruman, go!
Oh, I lost one guy.
Alright.
That's right, beat him up!
Wait, can I grab?
Grab a tree!
Do it!
Use a tree!
Grab another tree!
Oh my god, yes!
Okay, let's just claim this.
Oh wait, I can claim this automatically.
Fuck it.
Mine now, yoink!
Yoink, it's mine now.
Where's my ogre?
Wait, I only have two ogres?
Oh my god, get these guys.
Wait, where's his friend?
Where the fuck is his friend?
Yeah, use a tree against him!
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Okay, let's build this real fast.
And then we'll claim here.
Wait, who's attacking?
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Get out!
Oh my god, no!
How did you get here?
How the fuck did you get all the way here?
Oh, I don't think he's gonna live, guys.
No!
I don't even know how he got there!
How the fuck did he get there?
How did he get there?
Oh my god, I don't even know how he got there, guys.
I don't know what happened.
He just decided to live there for some fucking reason.
Oh my god.
My poor ogres.
I don't know what the fuck he was doing.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, what?
Where is he?
Oh my god, I forgot he even existed.
I forgot he was in my game.
What the fuck?
What are you doing here?
Alright, we still have our two ogres though.
Our two ogres with trees.
I don't know the shortcuts for this game.
So I'm just like caveman styling this right now.
Guys, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
I'm playing, I'm doing caveman style.
I don't know the shortcuts for this game.
Guys, this game came out in 2004.
Is it 2004?
Oh my god, does this game actually come out in 2004?
I don't remember.
Yeah, fuck that one guy.
Guys, it's been a while.
Yeah.
Oh my god, his entire family is dead.
His entire family is actually dead.
Let's grab this.
Get over here.
Who is shooting me?
Who is this one person that is shooting me?
Alright.
Nice.
Fucking...
I don't like how...
Okay.
I need to do this and then...
And then do...
Wait, where is it?
Okay.
There we go.
Saruman, I need you to use this real fast.
Get him out of here.
And then use this real fast too.
And then also do that.
And then...
And then let's just grab people in here.
Okay, it doesn't matter.
We don't have enough units.
That's alright.
Saruman, protect us!
Alright, it's time.
It's time to kill the trees.
It's your big moment, everybody.
Alright.
Saruman, you stay here.
And you watch in the side.
Oh, it's Q select all units?
Okay, nice.
Alright.
And then...
Fuck the trees.
It's time.
It's time to burn the forest.
Ever since...
Guys, you know what's even worse?
Groot is now sort of meta now.
In the high elos.
So this is like very therapeutic for me.
This is...
For some reason, Groot has become meta.
So like...
This is absolutely incredibly therapeutic right now.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Wait, they're all dead.
Wait a minute.
Wait, how are they all dead?
What?
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Wait, they're all dead.
Wait a minute.
Oh, fuck.
Wait, they're all dead.
Wait, how are they all dead?
Oh, help.
Help, sir.
I'm fucked up.
Oh.
Oh, fuck.
I'm fucked up.
Oh my god.
Keep running.
Oh, shit.
Quickly, sir.
Come on.
Quickly.
Oh, no, no.
No, no.
No.
I didn't press the subscribe.
Wait, can I rebuild Sorobot?
Oh my god, I can bring him back.
I can bring him back.
Guys, it's okay.
Guys, guys.
I can bring him back, guys.
I can bring Sorobot back.
Guys, I didn't know.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
What fucking BS3?
I didn't know.
Holy shit.
He's just stoned black.
I'm jumping down.
I am rude.
Your entire army died.
Don't you die.
Oh my god.
Bro, why is he so strong?
Holy shit.
He fucking died.
Oh my god.
He just killed them.
He killed them all.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Trees smacked the taste out of you.
He killed them all.
Just one guy.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm creating armory right now.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
The fuck do I do?
Is there anything?
Why is he so strong?
Holy shit.
Let me grab upgrades.
I just realized I didn't upgrade at all.
That makes a lot more sense.
Oh my god.
Okay, that was...
That was...
That was very scary, guys.
That was very scary.
Like, don't worry, he's coming back.
Saruman.
Welcome back, Saruman.
It's like nothing bad happened, guys.
It's like...
Guys, it's okay.
Nothing bad has happened.
We got it.
We just gotta wait for all our upgrades and then we should be fine.
Guys, we just need this.
We rebuilt him.
Guys, we can always rebuild.
Remember that.
We can rebuild and make them stronger.
Okay.
Alright, we can have this upgrade.
Okay, this time.
We can do this, guys.
Guys, this time.
Nothing can stop us now.
We should be fine.
Jesus Christ.
Why are they so strong?
Okay, alright.
I need to learn control groups for this one.
But, like, I can't be bothered right now.
Okay, we'll put these guys here.
Oh, my God.
Let's not put them over there.
No, no, no, no.
Get back.
No.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we're going in.
We're committing.
Okay.
Okay, okay, that's fine.
I believe.
And then, Soroban.
Right here.
Soroban, this is it.
Use the fire.
There we go.
That's right.
Chop him.
We're figuring it out, Soroban.
We're figuring it out.
It's okay.
They're too busy.
They're so busy.
He's dead, but, like, that's okay.
That's okay.
It's just okay.
It's me.
Oh, Soroban.
Soroban, get out of here.
Get out of here, Soroban.
That's okay.
Round two.
We have backup, guys.
It's okay.
Backup is coming.
Soroban, you just stay there and look pretty.
You just stay there and look pretty, Soroban.
It's fine.
That's right.
Everything is okay.
We just...
We did it.
Yay.
I can see why Groot is meta now.
We did it, guys.
Guys, I think they used their Namor-Groot combo on us.
Fuck the trees!
Who needs oxygen?
The less oxygen we have, the more I can bottle and sell for profit.
That's right.
Wait, what?
Why are there hobbits?
Who the fuck?
Why are you here?
Bro!
Alright, get out of here.
How are you level 10?
Get out!
Go back to your own movie!
Go back!
Get out of here!
Go back to the fucking Hobbitlands!
Go back to New Zealand!
Get out!
Go back to New Zealand, you fuckers!
This is my story!
The Shire!
Alright, back to where I...
Toki can't say that.
Alright, there you go.
Back to...
Back to what I'm actually here for.
Okay, we gotta get the fire out.
This is an RT stream because there's no strategy.
What do you mean?
There's so much strategy!
I killed the trees!
Is that not enough strategy?
I'm here to fuck the trees up!
That is plenty enough strategy, guys.
My strategy is to burn trees down.
Real-time game.
Not so Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Full choice of the elves to bring peace-loving farmers into war.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay!
We did it, guys!
We did it with no- We did it, guys.
I was not panicking at all.
Yay!
Calm, cool, and collected.
I can't believe the hobbits are level 10!
I literally have the fucking- the fucking evil wizard and he's level 3.
I didn't get to sing the Lorax Wunsler song again.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yay, I did it!
Like, how are they level fucking 10?
Who gave these hobbits XP?
Yay!
I hope Sauron is proud of me.
My hero.
I hope my hero saw what I did.
Yeah, fuck Groot.
Finally, so therapeutic.
I've like been banning Groot in almost all my ranked games now.
I fucking hate that character so much.
Alright, nice.
Yay!
We're doing it!
My oshi, Sauron!
Okay, do I kill all of the elves?
Wait, are these the elves?
Wait, who do I want to invade?
The Gap of Rohan?
If I destroy the forest even more, that means destroying forests.
Forests are made out of trees.
Trees can die.
And I hate trees.
Let's go there.
Yes.
No, I hate him.
I hate him.
Logical.
Yay!
Let's burn the Amazon!
No tree left standing.
Ogres don't need a fucking breeze.
Alright, let's get this.
And then...
Furnace.
This.
And then...
Where do I go?
I mean, I can always rebuild Sauron.
Fight off elves and ENTs.
Oh my god, thank god.
I get to kill two things I hate at once.
What's that?
Hello, goblins.
Get out of here.
Get out of here, lower fucking beings!
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
You really think you can beat me?
Get out of here, you lower beings.
Alright, wait.
There's the enemy?
Oh my god, what the fuck are they here already?
Wait, what?
Wait, already here?
Oh shit.
I was not ready for them to be here.
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
How are they already here?
What the fuck are these trees here?
Oh god, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I did not expect them to be here already.
I gotta build these, I guess.
Oh, that's bad.
Alright.
Okay, I did not expect them to be here.
Guys.
Oh, I get the big berserkers.
Where are the berserkers?
Okay.
Alright, nice.
Oh, where's Sormon?
Okay, we gotta let's do what I originally wanted to do.
Let's build this too.
Alright, I need to get this real fast.
And then get over here.
Deep berserk, okay.
That's great to know.
Thank god.
Thank god I knew exactly what that does.
Let's see.
Okay, so it's just goblins.
Alright, nice.
If it's just goblins, I can just do this.
And then...
we can claim...
I'll claim here.
And then...
Alright, nice.
Alright, fuck.
Guys, see?
I told you!
What do I have?
I don't have enough money.
Um... fuck!
Okay.
Okay, I need...
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I need... I'll buy more meat.
And then... because I need to build this.
Okay, and... Oh, shit!
Nice money!
That's what we needed.
Okay, steal this.
Yoink.
My now.
Provides food as a research.
Provides lumber.
Let's just get food.
Alright, and then we get another building right here.
See, guys?
Look at the strategy I'm doing right now.
And then...
Let me claim this.
Mine.
Yoink.
My now.
There you go.
See?
Look at all the strategy!
You guys said I can strategize.
What's this?
Vision?
Oh, I can get it for 15 sec... Is this strategy?
Yeah, yeah.
That's strategy.
I send units out and they die.
Is this not strategic enough?
Like...
I send people out and they die.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, oh, fuck.
Wait, they have horses?
Wait, that's not fair!
Why does mom let you have horses?
Oh, shit.
I have no one protecting the base.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Everything is fine.
Everything is fine, guys.
We need this.
And then...
Okay, this is a little awkward.
Okay, I need to claim this real fast.
Alright.
And then, let me build...
Oh, my head.
My...
There's so much...
I'm trying to...
What are these?
Are they just people?
What are the people gonna do?
They're just people.
Okay.
Everything is fine, guys.
See?
Everything is going okay.
And then I'll just claim this.
And then I'll just keep going.
Oh, and then I can cut trees.
Look at that.
Tree down.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Tree.
Okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
Don't worry.
I do not have enough command points.
Oh, they sent horses.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, this isn't fair.
Wait.
This is not fair.
Why did they get all of that?
Oh, shit.
Okay, don't worry.
I can rebuild.
I can rebuild, guys.
Guys, I can rebuild.
Everything will be fine.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
At least use your last dying breath to do fire.
Dying breath to do fire.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
This is fun.
This is so fun.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no.
Guys, this is fun.
This is fun.
Oh, this is so fun.
Just keep building arrows.
Just...
This is fun.
This is...
I'm sending people back.
Just keep building.
I'm okay.
Guys, I don't think this is fun no more.
Guys, this is not...
Oh, guys.
This is not fun.
Guys, this is not fun no more.
Oh, fuck.
This is not fun anymore, everyone.
Oh, my God.
I didn't think they would...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Don't worry.
Sorava's coming back and he'll clutch it.
I believe.
I believe in the Sorava clutch.
I have a Berserker coming in.
He's gonna go fucking crazy.
Watch this.
He's gonna go fucking...
Guys, my Berserker is dead.
Guys, my Berserker died so fast.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, guys.
It's okay.
As long as I keep cutting trees, it'll be fine.
Oh, guys.
This is...
This is not fun no more.
I didn't think they would that strong.
Oh, my God.
Please, Sorava.
Sorava, no.
And there's more.
Oh, no.
My last slaughterhouse.
Guys.
I think I really, really hate...
I think the dwarves were right.
Oh, my God.
Of course, they...
I think if we remove the elves...
If we remove the elves from this world, nothing good would be... Nothing would be lost.
That's all I'm saying.
And you can't be like, that's racist, Doki.
Because the elves are, like, the most racist of us all.
You can't say that.
Elves are even more racist than any of us.
So, like, in the end, they deserve it.
Can't be racist because it's true.
Alright.
You know what?
We don't... Let's just...
Let's... Let's go to the other... Let's do the other one.
Let's...
Let's... You know what?
We don't need the... Guys.
Guys.
We don't need to take over the forest, guys.
We don't need the forest.
That's fine.
We'll be here.
Things will be easier.
I believe.
Let's not rush into it this time.
Let's just chill.
Guys, we'll just...
We'll just chill here.
We won't rush into it this time.
We'll chill.
We're gonna chill here.
We're gonna...
We're just gonna relax.
We don't have to rush into it.
Things will be okay this time.
Anything here?
What the fuck?
I just got here!
Okay, we gotta build this.
That's so fucked up.
I literally just got here and they were like...
They assaulted...
They actually went in so fast.
Okay.
Let's defend here.
Let's go here for defense.
And then we'll keep building this.
Cause I don't...
How?
Oh, Saruman.
Sorry, Saruman will be fine.
I believe in him.
I believe in the power...
Oh, it's just humans.
We're fine.
It's just people.
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Alright, Saruman.
You're getting a little too cocky right now.
Alright, let's just chill here for a little bit.
You're getting a little too cocky.
We'll build more resources.
And then we should build another...
We'll build another furnace.
Alright.
Let's do Saruman and this guy.
The fuck?
Shoot back!
Are you really gonna...
Okay, we need a thousand... Okay, I want to build another furnace too.
Alright, things are fine.
Everything is okay, guys.
Everything is okay.
Okay.
Help him.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's... Whoa!
How did you didn't get this?
Okay.
Oh, that's awkward.
Okay, that's a little awkward.
How the fuck do they send an entire army?
Please!
Okay.
This is fine.
We'll make another rock base.
Oh, I don't think I can defend myself a second time.
Oh, this is... Oh, this is awkward.
It's okay.
I'll cut these trees.
We'll have our resources.
Alright, we have resources.
Everything is okay.
Everything is healthy.
We're so healthy.
We're so very healthy.
Everyone,
just keep defending.
Just keep defending.
Nothing to worry about.
Just keep Defending.
Um, we'll have Saruman back and then everything will be fine.
Oh.
All right, there we go.
We're so healthy.
We're still so healthy.
Oh, everything will be okay.
Everything will be okay.
Everything will be... Why do they get all of this?
Okay, um, all right, we just need a forge.
I need a... I need to buy the armory, but like, oh my god, I need more money.
I need more money.
It's okay, I'll just build another...
I'll build another... I'll build another this.
And then... and then I can put a berserker in here and then we'll have Saruman back and then things will be fine.
Things will be so healthy for us, guys.
I believe.
Okay, I'm gonna explore and see if I can get another base.
We need another base right now.
It's okay.
Evil always wins, right?
I never finished Lord of the Rings, but I'm pretty sure it's Surround 1, right guys?
Right, guys?
Yeah, I see.
Yeah, yeah.
As he should, right?
Yeah, Surround 1.
Yeah, how could he lose?
You know, you're right.
How could he lose?
Just how I remember it.
Yeah, I wish he would never lose.
So, evil always prevails.
Don't worry, he's back.
See, look.
He's back.
None shall oppose us.
I knew he'd make it.
Okay, I need a thousand three hundred.
It should be almost there.
I'm gonna wait until I have a thousand surrenders so I can build the armory.
Okay, let me check here.
Okay, I could take over their farms here.
Yeah, these are just regular people, right?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
The fuck are you doing here?
Get in there, Berserker!
Wait, are these just regular people?
Even better.
All right, all right.
I should have enough now.
Furnace, furnace.
Let's build another.
All right.
I'll put this here and then we go in.
We're gonna pillage, guys.
Just like how my Oshu always wanted.
We pillage.
What are you gonna do?
Fight back?
Oh, shit!
Wait, wait, they fight back?
Oh my god!
That's not how I remembered.
They can fight back?
Okay, wait, where's my- oh, there it is.
Okay, heavy armor.
Okay, we need all these upgrades.
Nice.
My farm now.
Now they're fighting back.
I know!
That's so illegal!
Wait, what?
Where's the cave troll?
Okay, get the trees in.
We need trees.
All right, kill them!
They're defenseless!
Kill them!
Oh my god, they're defenseless!
My favorite!
I shouldn't imagine what the one ring would do to Toki.
Nice.
All right, nice.
We have money, too.
We need that money.
All right, good.
Oh my god, they're trying to run away!
Get her!
No mercy.
I can't believe they would try and run away.
Wait, what?
Where?
No, they're not.
Okay, let's grab the gold here.
Oh my god, these guys are so much more easier than elves.
It's like they're like- it's like they're like innocent civilians or something.
Wait, where?
Oh shit!
Okay.
All right, that's fine.
No worries.
I'm coming back.
Don't worry.
They'll never expect a back shot.
I also need to cut these trees, too.
Let me- let me cut these trees just for extra.
Okay, nice.
And then I need to upgrade these and...
All right.
Okay, get ready.
Save- save our trees.
All right.
Oh shit.
Oh.
All right, Sarma, I need you to help me.
I need you to help me over here.
Don't worry, I'm coming back.
Wait, Sarma, are you just gonna let them- what the fuck, Sarma?
Sarma's like, they can handle this.
They'll be fine.
They can handle this.
You know what?
Fuck it.
You guys get all the upgrades.
Oh, that would be so fucked if, like, before they get this upgrade, they all just die.
No, they'll be fine, right?
Oh shit.
Okay, um, let me grab all of these guys real fast and put them here.
And then- oh shit, my trees!
No!
My trees!
Not my trees!
They're gonna build a- oh, I'm mad.
I'm fucking mad.
I'm mad.
I can't believe they just built it over.
That's so fucked.
That's actually fucked.
I can't believe they just did that.
They just, like, built over my thing.
Oh my god.
They just built over it.
Again?
Oh my god, please.
Please, for the love of- stop.
Just stop.
Please, just stop.
Let me, like, have a moment.
Let me- it's- everything is so fast, I don't even have time to fucking breathe.
Species, thank you for the 10 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, everything is so fast.
I swear to god, I have, like, no time to actually, like, process what the fuck I have to do.
I just have to, like- I'm just going in and things happen.
Okay, all right, I need to grab- I need to put this and then- do I even have money?
I don't, it's 2000.
I need- I need, like, money.
It's almost like you gotta do it in real time.
Okay, we slowly surround them.
I believe.
Okay, we need to make sure all of us is fully upgraded, though.
All right, Tormund, you- you guard this one area yourself.
I believe in you.
All right, look at all these guys getting ready.
Okay, we'll guard here.
All right, shoot back.
Guys, are you really- oh my god, do I need to, like- oh my- they didn't even shoot back!
Guys!
Shoot back!
Guys, oh my god.
Guys, do I have to hold your hand?
Do I actually have to hold your hand?
They, like- they just let them shoot them.
Okay, things- everything's fine.
Everything's fine.
Everything is so- okay.
All right, we just gotta- I wanna make enough so I can make this.
My evil raider orcs are not known for their intelligence.
Like, what are you doing?
They're just shooting you for free!
It's all right.
He's got this.
Like this.
Goodbye.
Nice.
See, I told you that he can take those.
He can take them.
Okay, that has to be a big house.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
That's good that this is a big house.
All right, and then I And then I'll make one for units.
And then... arrow.
Arrow.
Surma's fine, right?
Surma, please!
You're getting shot at!
Don't just let them shoot you!
You're stronger than them!
Okay, nice.
I don't like how he just lets it happen sometimes.
I don't like how he just sits there and be like, okay.
He's just- it's like he wants to die!
It's like- okay, money.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Okay, Surma definitely won't- okay.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, everything is fine.
I just do this.
Inspire!
There we go!
I believe!
Fire!
There we go.
And then we chop the trees!
Tree chop!
Okay.
All right, we just gotta upgrade everybody and then we should be fine.
Don't worry!
There's no way he'll die!
Oh, wait!
I forgot you can integrate!
Oh my god, I forgot about that!
Become one!
I forgot you can integrate together!
Wait!
Okay, I forgot about that.
All right, you guys are best friends now.
We're best friends.
Okay, we're ready.
We're so ready.
Oh my god, I forgot about the integration.
Okay, we're so ready.
I think we're ready.
They're attacking us!
Kill them!
Goodbye!
Our Berserker is almost dead, but that's okay!
Okay, I'm gonna put these guys here and then...
All right, things will be okay.
All right, guys!
We can do this!
I believe in us!
I don't know what this does, but...
I don't know what it does, but fuck it!
That's how I like to play my video games.
I could have read it, but like fuck it.
All right, so...
It's time!
Go!
We fight!
Oh my god, we can't get past!
We're stuck!
It's okay!
We're stuck, but it's...
We're stuck but that's all right!
I don't know, I think I'm doing it.
It's fine!
Just do whatever the fuck you want!
Just kill everything!
I believe!
There we go!
Just kill everything!
Die for... die for us!
Wait, what's this?
There we go, nice!
We did it, guys!
I think we're winning.
Are we winning?
I...
You know what?
Fuck it, let's all just fuck this one building up.
Let's go.
I'll even use fire.
You know what?
Fuck it.
They don't know the horses, they're confused!
They're so confused!
That's it!
I'm gonna take you down!
That's right!
Oh, wait, this doesn't work against horses.
I just figured it out.
It doesn't work against horses, guys.
Look at that.
Let me cut up some trees just for good luck.
Just fuck these trees in general.
It's okay, Suramon, you'll be fine, Suramon.
Guys, I don't think...
Guys, I think he might die.
It's okay, I can rebuild him.
I can rebuild him.
I can...
What do we do?
He's dead!
It's okay, guys.
I can rebuild him, guys.
I can rebuild him!
How is he still making horses?!
How is he still making horses?
It's okay.
Things will be fine.
Wait, they took over?
Wait, what?
They took over my farm at the last second?
Oh shit.
Wait a minute.
Wait, they're recovering.
How is that possible?
They're recovering.
Stop making horses!
Stop!
I can't do anything about it!
They keep making horses!
Get these horses out of here!
Oh my god.
Get them out.
Stop!
Oh my god.
They keep making horses.
I don't know what to do.
They keep making horses, guys.
What the fuck do I do?
I'm literally... I died because of this!
Because... Oh my god!
I can't believe I died because of the fucking horses.
I'm so mad.
Oh my god.
It's because of the stupid fucking horses.
That's actually crazy.
The horses actually won!
The power of... What the fuck?
Get them out!
Get them
out of here!
Get them out!
Oh my god.
The stupid fucking farm.
Get the farm out!
Curse of Genghis Khan.
Bro, I swear to god.
I swear to god.
If you make another... I swear to god.
If you make another farm.
I swear to fucking god.
Get out.
Oh my god.
Get the fuck out!
You stupid villager.
Oh my god.
They're doing this again!
Part two.
The stupid fucking farm is still going.
I'm fucking sending the entire army to destroy this one farm.
I don't care.
I do not care.
Get out.
This is my farm.
This is my...
This is my fucking farm.
Jesus Christ.
This stupid fucking farm.
Kill him.
Fucking kill him.
It's Lord Ackroyd.
These stupid horses.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna come over and fucking send a fireball into these horses.
I don't fucking care.
Send a fireball.
Kill them.
There we go.
Get them out of here.
Alright.
Oh my god.
How many horses?
How many?
Oh my... Oh my god.
They fucking rebuild.
I'm cutting these trees.
Okay.
Get over here.
I don't care.
I'm fucking destroying this.
This is a... I don't care.
Get these horses first.
Saurabhine, who cares?
Your mission?
Destroy this.
I don't care.
Saurabhine, you won't die just to kill this.
I don't... I don't care.
No, help him.
Help Saurabhine.
Help him.
Destroy the horse building.
Stop everything else.
That's... Get the horses.
Oh my... Okay, now you can do whatever.
Oh my god.
That's all we need you to destroy.
We just need you to destroy the horse building.
Alright.
That's fine.
Now you can do whatever the fuck you want.
Fuck it.
Destroy this farm.
Oh my god.
Are these villagers fucking crazy?
There we go.
Alright.
Everything is okay now.
I... I almost lost because of the horses.
I...
The great Heisenberg.
God, this is still unstable.
They just wouldn't stop.
They kept making horses.
Like, I don't understand.
Where do they get all these horses from?
Where do they all come from?
Stop.
Defenseless humans.
The world could use... That took way too long.
Let's just try the 1v1 Saurabhine.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, you... Bro, that took way too long.
That took... This is medium.
I don't understand.
It's just like... They were like popping out like fucking rabbits.
Horses do not... Horses take years to be bred.
But... But why...
Why the fuck... Why were they being popped out like rabbits?
It just kept coming.
It never stopped.
I survived.
I fucking survived the great horse war.
The whole army gone because of horses.
Oh my god.
It's a magic joke.
Who taught these humans to breed their horses?
I thought they were regular people.
I don't understand.
Alright, it's okay.
We got... We got Rohan.
We can do it.
We got Rohan.
When the fuck do I get my wolf riders?
Oh my god.
When the fuck... When the fuck do I get to... When the fuck do I get to have my riders?
It is Rohan, land of the horse lads.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
That was very exhausting.
Merry Pippin!
That's me!
I win, right?
Oh my god.
This is just like the movies when I kill them.
Alright.
Here we go.
Wait, what?
What's wrong?
Oh shit.
What can they do?
Guys!
Guys, how did we... Oh guys, I fucked up already.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
This is... It's fine.
You know what?
I can take all of these myself.
I can take them.
I can totally take them.
Do they have like special abilities?
Oh!
I can toggle the weapon.
You know what?
Fuck it.
One of them should be both.
Okay, let's go.
Let's just grab more guys here and then let's get some money too real quick.
Alright, nice.
Everything will be fine.
As always, guys.
Everything will be so fine.
I believe in us.
Okay, let's grab some heals.
It's okay.
They're not gonna run away.
We'll be fine.
No way they can run away.
There's no way, right?
Oh shit.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
See, look at that.
Famous last words.
What are you gonna do?
Run away?
Okay, let's bring over here.
Let's put more people here.
That's right.
Flee!
You think I'm scared?
I literally just beat up some trees.
I beat up horses.
You think I'm scared?
I'm literally beat up.
Wait, take control of the summit of Amon Hen?
Is this summit of Amon Hen?
Is that it?
Oh shit!
What the fuck?
What did I do?
Oh, I did it.
I just ran through.
I did it.
It's that easy.
Bro, fucking kill them!
Kill them!
Oh my god.
It's not that difficult!
Just shoot them!
Oh shit.
Okay, maybe it is a little difficult, guys.
Maybe...
Oh shit.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, fuck off!
It's okay.
Okay, you guys, you guys chill.
You guys, you guys chill a little bit.
Guys, it was a little...
Guys, it was definitely a lot more difficult than I expected, guys.
It was... yeah, yeah.
Who would have thought?
Who would have thought they were a lot stronger?
Yeah, they do a lot of damage!
Who would have thought?
Oh my god, those fucking elves!
I blame the elves.
It's okay.
These two will just chill a little bit until I figure out what to do.
Fight back!
What?
Holy shit!
Who is this one guy that's killing me?
Oh my god, no wonder!
One fucking... I was like, who is that guy fucking 1v6ing me?
Oh, that makes a lot of sense now.
Okay, I realize why.
Guys, I understand now.
I understand.
Is he still alive?
Okay, guys, we did it.
We killed Gimli.
We fucking did it.
Guys, we rewrote history.
We killed Gimli.
We fucking did it.
We... OH MY GOD, AND THEN THERE'S LEGOLAS!
NOT TO DEAL WITH LEGOLAS!
Oh no!
Oh my god!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I can do it again.
Oh my god, it's okay.
Legolas is a... Oh, we did it!
We rewrote history yet again!
We did it!
Oh my god, we fucking did it!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, who would've thought that got a lot easier when we killed him?
The fellowship has ended, just like in the movies.
What an ending, guys!
We did it.
Wait, reinforcements?
Are you serious?
They got away?
How?
I killed them!
Wait, how did... How?
Kill all the heroes and the hobbits.
No.
We can't let them take that boat.
Wait, that's not fair!
That's... Wait, that's absolutely not fair!
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
It's not fine, but it's also fine.
It's fine.
Where's my... Where is he?
Wait, the fucking horse... Oh my god.
I'm trying.
I'm trying my best right now.
No!
My fucking trees!
Not the... Where's the pikes?
Where's the... I don't have pikes!
What do you mean, pikes?
What do you mean?
How do I make pikes, guys?
Wait, where is he?
Where's Olok?
Wait, where did Olok go?
Olok!
It's bugged?
I can't make... Oh, wait!
I can make my pikemen!
Oh god.
Oh god!
Oh my god, they realized I had pikemen!
Get the horses.
Okay, I have one guy left.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay.
I got pike... Guys, I did it!
My first pikemen, guys!
I did it!
Get together!
Oh my god, finally!
I am no longer afraid of horses!
I am no longer... I'm no longer... No!
I'm fucked up!
I didn't wait for my trees!
Oh, fuck!
Okay, I messed up a little bit, guys.
I messed up a little bit and forgot to...
Guys, it's okay.
We just need to wait four minutes, guys.
I can... Wait, there's gold here.
Guys, guys, it's okay.
We're gonna be saved by this random gold pile.
There we go!
Oh my god, we can make trees again.
We can make trees again!
Oh my god!
Oh, thank god!
Oh, we have reinforcements!
It's okay.
We have... We have cave trolls!
Guys, look at that!
Nothing to worry about, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
We're okay.
Alright, never punish!
Let's go!
Never punish, guys!
Never punish!
Alright, here we go.
We did it.
We lost one guy, but we did it.
We lost...
Let's put him right here!
Nothing bad happened.
Alright, there we go.
Go in!
Let's go!
That's right!
Fight!
That's good.
Okay, then I can build more pikemen.
And I'll put them right here.
And then things will be... Oh my god, I got my trolls too.
I got my trolls.
See, look at that!
Nothing bad has happened!
It's not like I was economically fucked for a minute!
Guys, it's fine!
Look at that!
Nothing bad ever happens to me!
Okay, we have to go this way.
Yeah, we have to go this way.
Alright, ogres.
It's okay.
Oh shit!
What the fuck?!
How the fuck?!
Wait!
What the fuck?!
Who are these people?!
They just killed everybody!
What?!
What the fuck?!
What happened?!
Is this... Oh my god, it was you!
It was you!
I'm coming over!
I'm fucking coming over!
I will kill this hobbit!
Oh my god, it's Aragorn!
Oh my god!
It's Aragorn!
Pippin!
And who the fuck is this guy?
Merry, okay.
My dad died so fast!
Jesus Christ!
They're all here!
The whole family is here!
Jesus!
Did I even kill...
Oh my god, get him!
Get him!
One angry troll!
Oh, that's right!
Who's this guy?
Haldir?!
Why are they all here?!
Do I just win?
Do I just take over the lands after?
Wait, guys.
If I kill them all, then I should just win, right?
Wait, I should just win after that!
They'd just all be dead!
What is Haldir doing here?
What is he doing?
Let's ignore Merry.
He's not that important.
Wait, is this Pippin?
Let's just ignore Pippin.
He's not that important.
You don't know.
Fuck it.
Let's all just fuck up Pippin real quick.
Let's just fuck him up.
Yeah, that's right.
Kill Pippin.
Just fuck Pippin in particular.
Who cares?
Surround him!
Yeah!
We did it!
The good end!
Yeah!
Let's go!
What?!
We killed all your friends.
That's fine.
What the fuck is Frodo gonna do?
We killed all his friends anyway.
Bye Sam!
That's right.
Sam and Frodo had to watch us kill Gimli and...
Gimli, Aragorn, Merry, Pippin, Legolas and the rest.
We won the war!
Yeah, we conquered it.
Sam can still...
The fellowship is broken!
Yay!
I killed the king.
I'm the king now.
Alright, what's next?
I don't wanna deal with the trees, guys.
Guys, I don't know if I wanna deal with the trees, guys.
Guys, I think the one thing I'm afraid of at the moment...
I'm... oh man.
Oh man, I don't know.
They can keep the trees.
I'll just... I'll surround them.
I'll take the rest of the territory around me.
After that one time, yeah, no, I've learned my lesson, guys.
I've learned my lesson.
No, no, of course not.
Of course not.
The bad guys are the people who lose.
If we win, we're not the bad guys.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I assume they'll be like here.
So... oh shit, what?
This is where the army is?
I'll build these and then I'll build the hut here.
Ooh.
I can upgrade.
Do I want the Eye of Sauron?
Stealth, leadership bonus, and fear.
Plus 50.
Ooh, we should get that.
Or plus 3,000.
Ooh!
I wanna get that.
I want the resource upgrades.
Let's see.
I feel like I have to prepare.
Uh...
Ooh, I wanna... I wanna...
Where?
Already?!
I just got here!
What the fuck?!
I literally just got here.
You know what?
I can 1v1 these.
I can 1v1 this.
I literally just got here.
Like, excuse me?
Like, chill, please?
Yeah, I can 1v1 the wards.
He can not 1v1 that.
He can not.
Okay, this is like not fair.
This is...
This is not fair.
Like, excuse me?
I just started the game!
I... what?!
How?
What?!
I just started!
He just surfed and R.
How do I build faster?
How do I build faster?!
That's not fair!
How the fuck do I build faster?!
This is... this is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
How do I...
This is... this is actually fucked up.
This is so fucked up.
Like, I just started!
Oh my god!
I just started it!
No!
My camp!
What do I do?!
I don't have any...
What?!
What the fuck?!
Just let me die!
And then he builds a farm in front of me!
That's so fucked!
That's so... stop being a crybaby!
I literally just started and then they send an... what?!
I don't... what the fuck?!
I just started!
Build a farm... like, there was no way for me to play faster!
Every skill issue.
Gordon, thank you.
Superchat, thank you.
Thank you.
I literally started the game up, built my house, and then, like, an entire army showed up!
I don't understand how I could have played that better!
I don't understand!
I legitimately don't understand!
I just started the game!
That was crazy!
I had, like, no moment to, like... I had no moment of rest.
Oh my god!
They showed up!
They're here!
Okay.
Things are okay for now.
It's just one horse.
It's just one horse for now.
Oh, there they come!
Here they come!
I don't trust.
I don't trust them.
I need more reinforcements.
Oh my god!
I hope things are okay!
I'm staying here!
Oh, I don't have much, much people left, though.
I don't have enough.
Oh my god, I survived the first attack!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, there's more!
There's more!
Oh, you stayed back.
You're still alive.
They keep going.
Okay.
I need more money.
Oh, he's coming in!
Oh, I don't have...
Oh, I don't have much!
Please!
Oh, I'm surviving!
I'm surviving right now.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
I'm building as fast as I can!
Jesus Christ!
It's okay.
There's more horses, guys!
There's more!
Oh my god, there's more horses.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, slowly.
It's fine.
Everything is okay.
It's not okay, but everything is okay.
I don't feel okay right now, but it's okay.
Everything is okay.
And there's... there's so much!
There's so many!
Oh, you're crazy!
You're fucking crazy!
Go back!
Oh, I don't have a lot of money.
I don't have a lot!
Please, I have so little!
I have so little!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, just do this.
Um.
That's fine.
We'll put more arrows.
Just... mission survive!
Just survive!
I almost have reinforcements!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Survive!
You're the villain!
Why do you need money?
Please, have mercy on me!
Have... have mercy, please!
It's for the enemy reinforcements!
God, I'm so fucked!
I'm so fucking... I'm so fucking... I'm so...
Oh, fuck!
What do you mean they're for the enemy reinforcements?
I need them more!
I'm... What do you mean?
I... Oh!
Jesus!
I... I need them so much more!
No, my arrows!
My arrows!
Somebody send help!
Oh, no!
I'm cutting trees down!
I'm fucking increasing the resources!
I'm... I'm sending them out!
Oh, my God!
Have
mercy!
Have mercy on me!
Holy fuck!
Oh, thank God!
No mercy!
Please!
Okay.
More arrows!
Oh, fuck!
Oh, no!
More pikemen!
Oh, fuck!
Not the reinforcements!
Oh, shit!
Oh, no!
Oh, fuck!
No!
Oh, shit!
I'm trying!
They're coming!
Oh, no!
They're all here!
I fought!
These are my last remaining army!
No!
Not the horses!
Please!
Oh, goodbye!
Goodbye!
Not the horses!
Please, just give me the pikemen!
Wait!
If I keep building these, it'll be fine!
I think I can live!
I just gotta keep building these!
Not the horses!
Anything but the pikemen!
Pikemen!
Reinforcements!
Okay.
Things are fine.
Oh, my God!
We just keep...
Just keep building these!
Just keep building these and everything will be fine!
I just keep... Oh, my God!
Everything will be fine!
Oh, my God!
My poor pikemen!
Okay.
Alright.
I lived.
I fucking lived.
What even...
Oh, destroy all the good forces!
Oh, my God!
Please!
I need to survive first!
My first mission is to fucking survive!
Okay.
It's fine.
We go in.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
We stabilized.
Guys, I don't know how we did it, but we stabilized.
I don't know how we did it, guys.
Those are still... Oh, my God!
Oh, my God!
Okay.
I'm gonna take this farm.
I believe... Oh, fuck!
They're building an army right now.
We'll take this farm!
We're gonna take this farm!
We're gonna... Oh, come on!
How are they beating my pikemen?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
That's okay.
I fucking... That is not okay.
They just destroyed my pikemen.
Oh, no!
Oh, my God!
Oh, this is so rough.
This is so fucking rough.
How did my pikemen die?
Oh, my God!
How did they die?
How did they fucking die?!
Okay.
We built another siege.
This is the only way.
We just need to keep defending.
Guys, I can't upgrade.
I'm just trying to survive.
You don't understand.
My only mission is to live.
I just... Oh, my God!
Okay.
Things are okay.
Now we have like... Now we have extra.
Okay.
Now I can take this farm.
Wait.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God!
Why are you just letting them shoot you?!
Okay.
That's fine.
We don't let them just shoot us, you know?
We don't... We don't just let them... Guys.
Guys.
Stop just letting them shoot you like that.
Please.
That's all I ask.
How?
Why?
I can't.
I'm just... Just kill these villagers.
I'm gonna use this just for this farm.
Is this overkill?
Maybe.
But like, you don't understand.
I'm so done.
You don't understand.
I'm... I'm so done with this.
Just... I need this to be over.
Just kill them.
You can chill.
Okay.
So like, we'll be fine now.
This should be like... This is workable.
We can work with this.
We can definitely work with this.
There we go.
We finally got our... We got what we wanted.
Guys.
Guys, this is... Guys, we salvaged this.
We actually... Guys.
We salvaged it.
Guys, we did it.
We did it.
We fucking did it.
I'm so proud of us.
We actually lived.
Oh my god.
We did it.
The dream is alive.
Everyone.
It's alive.
Get the horses.
We are living the dream.
Get the people.
We're doing it.
Get them.
Okay.
Well, you got stuck.
Okay, I'm gonna kill these guys in particular.
Alright.
It's fine.
The dream is absolutely alive right now.
Oh my god.
We actually did it.
We're actually... Okay, now we need to get rid of this so I can actually build a siege weapon.
So I can afford... I can afford a siege weapon.
That's right.
It's my turn.
That's fucking... Oh shit.
You go back home though.
You go back home.
That's fucking right.
It's my turn.
Alright, now I just need a siege.
Alright.
Let's get that batarang.
And then get that thing here.
Alright, now I'm ready.
I'm ready.
No, these are bait.
These are bait.
Oh my god.
Where did all these horses come from?
But it's okay.
It's okay.
I'm ready for real now.
That was bait.
That was me mowing them down.
They're so cooked.
I have everything I need.
I'm so ready now.
This is fine.
I'll put two batarangs just in case because I don't believe myself.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go.
Where's the other guy?
Alright, go help him.
What the fuck?
What do you mean there's extra horses?
Let's go.
This is fine.
And then we'll have extra.
And then I'm gonna cut trees too.
And then we're gonna get rid of these guys as well.
That's right.
And then we're gonna get rid of these guys.
And then.
And then we go up.
How are they making so many people?
Okay.
Alright.
We have our two batarang rams.
We're gonna slowly head up.
Jesus Christ.
The forest alive.
It's time.
Where's my batarang?
Get over here.
Alright.
I'm ready.
Get over here.
Oh shit, not the horses.
Oh shit.
Okay.
Maybe I'm not ready.
Oh no.
It's okay.
They're all distracted.
They're all distracted, guys.
They're all so distracted, everyone.
That's right.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
Get over here.
Oh, everybody's dead.
Okay, everybody's dying.
Okay, maybe I'm not as ready.
You go over here.
Um, they're all dead.
I just realized.
Wait, wait, wait.
I have a plan.
Watch this.
You go in there and then he leaves.
Oh shit.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh, where did this army come from?
Where the fuck did they come from?
Wait.
Oh wait.
They just showed up out of nowhere.
Where the fuck did they come from?
Okay, I was not expecting that.
They like, they like showed up out of nowhere.
How was I supposed to know?
How the fuck?
Okay, we need upgrade.
Okay, now we can destroy this and then get upgrades.
Now we can actually get upgrades.
Okay.
Things will be okay, guys.
Things will be okay.
Everyone, just start believing.
Things will be fine.
You have alerted the Horde.
Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
What?
Okay, things will be fine.
We just gotta rebuild the army.
Okay, alright, now we rebuild the army and you actually get upgrades, guys.
Now we upgrade.
Okay, don't stop believing.
We're rich now.
We're so rich.
Don't stop believing.
We're so healthy.
We will get all the horses.
We will get back the horses, guys.
Don't worry.
We will have the horses.
Okay, let's all like, let's all calm down, everyone.
Let's all calm down.
Oh my god.
Okay.
See ya.
Alright, I need to make sure...
Okay, we gotta get this upgraded.
Alright, see guys, look.
It's all fine.
We're getting the upgrades.
And then we have armor now.
Guys, we're so healthy.
We have armor now.
Nothing can kill us now.
We should be able to upgrade our, like, arrow shit, too.
Look at that.
Nothing can kill.
Now we have all the upgrades.
Except for the fire arrow.
Except for the fire arrow, but we almost have all the upgrades.
Okay.
Integrate together.
You're now best friends.
Alright, I need you guys to be best friends, guys.
Oh, I have no money.
Okay, this is, oh, that's awkward.
That's awkward.
I did a lot of upgrades.
It's okay.
I have this.
There we go.
And then I can do this.
Get rid of all the trees.
There we go.
Now I have all the money.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Oh, we're broke again.
But that's fine.
That's fine.
We have the army.
We have the army, guys.
Oh, back out, because you guys are...
Back out, because you guys don't know what rage is.
Back out.
Alright, nice.
With buddy, we're so healthy.
Okay.
And then...
Grab the armor.
We have everything, right?
Alright.
Look at that.
This is it.
This is the run.
Don't... This is the run.
This is... Oh my god, that dog.
No, no, no, no!
No!
Not the horses!
Anything but the horses.
No!
Oh my god.
Why?
I was so ready.
We were all so ready.
It's okay.
Everything is fine.
My people... My people are doing okay.
I believe in my people.
This is it.
Did they rebuild?
They rebuilt their fucking...
That should be illegal.
That... Oh my god.
I didn't realize they can rebuild.
I didn't...
It's okay.
All my men are okay.
They can rebuild too.
They can also rebuild.
I don't have horses!
It's okay.
I can also rebuild.
I... It's fine.
I can fix this.
We're so fine.
Alright.
This is the final countdown.
Oh no.
Get out of here.
I don't trust you guys.
You guys are just gonna die.
Alright.
The RTS and R sets for rebuild.
It's okay.
We can also rebuild.
We can all rebuild, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
We just gotta wait for our...
Oh my god.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I forgot.
I don't have command points.
Oh my god.
Alright.
One of you guys have to die.
Goodbye.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
What do we not need?
Fuck!
Okay.
We're sending you to your deaths.
Goodbye.
I need... Goodbye.
You're gonna have to die to this so I can get this.
Goodbye.
Oh seven.
Oh my god.
Goodbye.
Your sacrifice was not in vain.
I swear to god.
It was for a good cause.
Do not worry.
I swear to god.
If those horses ran in, I swear to fucking god.
Okay.
Alright.
It's time.
Okay.
It's time for real.
It's okay.
For real.
It's time.
It's time for real.
It's for real.
Real Zs.
We're not fucking around no more.
I'm gonna cut these trees down too for good luck.
Alright.
Here we go.
Get over there.
Where are my two guys?
Okay.
This is fine.
Alright.
Here we go.
Get over here.
You gotta break the thing again.
We need you to break the thing again.
Alright.
This time.
We can make this work this time.
Alright.
There we go.
Get them.
Alright.
You too.
How?
Help him.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
For real this time.
For real.
We can do this.
Go.
Kill everything.
For real.
Just kill everything.
Oh my god.
This time.
Go.
For real.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
No.
Not the horses.
Get the horses out of here.
No.
Not the horses.
Don't make me do this again.
No.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
They're gonna refill.
No.
Please no.
Do not refill.
I'm sending them in.
I swear to god.
Do not rebuild.
I cannot.
I cannot do this again.
Please.
I cannot.
Do not do this to me.
I can't.
I cannot.
Please.
Don't do this to me.
No.
They're gonna refill.
Oh my god.
I can't.
This is gonna be an endless war.
This war.
This war is endless.
I can't.
They're just gonna keep refilling.
I fucking can't.
I can't.
There's too many horses.
Oh my god.
No.
It's never gonna end.
I fucking can't.
I can't guys.
I can't anymore.
Oh no.
They're never gonna update.
They're just gonna keep refilling.
The horses.
They're crashing out.
Oh my god.
The horses.
There's too many horses.
I can't.
I'm gonna crash out.
How many times do I have to break the door?
How many times?
Oh my god.
I can't do this.
I can't.
This is what happens in the movies.
No more horses.
Same time next week.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There were so many.
There were so many horses.
Thank you for the super chat.
There was just so many horses.
What do I do?
They just keep making more horses.
I don't understand.
I can't.
They're too stuck.
I can't anymore.
Stop.
Unlucky.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Let's have a moment of silence for those who perished by the name of the horses.
The famous limit break horse.
The horses will win this war.
Oh my god.
I did not expect all the horses.
They just kept building their army.
They kept rebuilding.
I don't understand.
How do these animals keep growing?
How do they keep popping out horses?
They take like four to five years to grow.
Oh my god.
I need to cool down.
The horses just kept breeding.
Oh my god.
That was fun though.
That was really fun.
I got overwhelmed by all the horses.
The elves fucked me up.
The elves and the ENTs fucked me up.
And then the stables kept pumping them out like rabbits.
And then I was like...
I needed to put the game down.
I needed...
Or I was actually going to go outside and punch a horse.
I was going to fight a horse.
I was going to eat horse meat.
I would 100% google a restaurant.
And I'm going to buy four stacks of glue.
Or some shit.
And I'm going to go to Ikea and buy their meatballs.
Like I don't fucking care anymore.
I'll find a mountie and I'm going to slap that horse's ass.
And I was like... I'm going to kill you.
Oh my god.
I have become the horse auntie.
I didn't even realize there were faces around the main face.
I found that out when I did the...
The fog of war thing.
I did the fog of war and there was a face right next to me.
And at that point I was done.
I was done.
Oh.
Alright guys.
I'm going to call it here.
I hope you guys enjoyed today's stream.
Today's battle of miller stream.
At least I killed the fellowship.
At least I got to kill Gimli, Legolas, and the rest.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys.
Bye.